every year scientists at the UN collate
all the different climate change
promises made by countries across the
planet and try to work out what that
will mean their new calculations have
just been released showing that while
there's been some improvement there's
still a long way to go
let's take temperature first of all
today the UN says that all the climate
commitments made so far will get us to
2.5 degrees Celsius of warming by 2050
has a very slight Improvement on last
year which was 2.7 degrees but this is
where we should be by 2050. limiting
warming to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels that's the best
case and would help us avoid the very
worst effects of climate change one
degree may not sound like much but it is
enough to dramatically increase the
impact of climate change on things like
sea level rises and severe events like
flooding drought and heat waves now
let's have a look at carbon dioxide
emissions another key metric here's
where we were last year after the UN
assessment predicted that emissions
would be up by 13.7 percent by 2030
compared to 2010 levels with emissions
continuing to rise there's actually been
an improvement this year current
commitments will increase emissions by
slightly less 10.6 percent by 20 30 and
will rise no further
but here's the bad news it's still
nowhere near enough this is where we
should be according to the UN emissions
need to be cut by 45 percent by 2030. if
we are to stay on track the 1.5 degrees
of warming so why do we have this huge
gap between what's been pledged and
what's needed well these dots represent
the 193 Nations that signed that famous
Paris climate agreement pledge to keep
global warming well below two degrees
and ideally at 1.5 last year at the cop
26 U.N climate Summit in Glasgow they
all promised to increase or update their
plans every single year well now we're
just a few weeks from the cop 27 climate
Summit in Egypt and only 24 countries
including the UK have submitted new
plans but lots of others like the U.S
and China have not
this all comes as the World
Meteorological organization warns that
atmospheric levels of carbon dioxide
nitrous oxide and especially Methane
have all reached record levels the world
leaders gathering in Egypt next month
there is a lot of work to do